It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees, Google FiWireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization
现在正值授粉高峰期，我的业务发展迅猛。为了保证花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是为什么我选择 Google Fi Wireless。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这绝对是一个不会常有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。除税费和政府规费外，Google Fi Wireless 在网络高使用率期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。
during times of high network usage. For many new parents, the first weeks and months after their baby is born are a time of deep bonding and bewildering changes between sleepless nights, scrambled schedules, and learning to meet the needs of a tiny infant. Many new fathers and mothers feel like their world has been turned upside down overnight. Now it turns out those changes may go even deeper than parents realize. In recent years, scientists have found evidence that becoming a parent can change the structure and function of a person's brain.
对许多新手父母来说，宝宝出生后的头几周和几个月是深度建立亲密感以及经历令人应接不暇的变化的时期，伴随着不眠之夜、被打乱的日程，以及学习如何满足一个小婴儿的需求。许多新手父亲和母亲感觉自己的世界在一夜之间天翻地覆。现在看来，这些变化可能比父母们意识到的还要深远。近年来，科学家们发现有证据表明，成为父母可以改变一个人的大脑结构和功能。
And crucially, these changes happen to fathers as well as to mothers. So how does parenthood change us? What brain hormonal and other shifts occur in new moms and dads? Do these changes look different in men than in women? Or does becoming a father or a mother change the brain in the same way? What advantages and risks might these changes confer? And what does this research suggest about the best ways to support people through the transition to parenthood to benefit both parents and children.
至关重要的是，这些变化不仅发生在母亲身上，也发生在父亲身上。那么，为人父母是如何改变我们的呢？新妈妈和新爸爸的大脑、荷尔蒙以及其他方面发生了哪些转变？这些变化在男性和女性身上看起来有什么不同？还是说成为父亲或母亲会以同样的方式改变大脑？这些变化可能会带来哪些优势和风险？这项研究对帮助人们顺利过渡到父母角色、从而造福父母双方和孩子的最佳方法有何启示？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Darby Saxby. Dr. Saxby is an associate professor of psychology at the University of Southern California, where she leads the neuroendocrinology of social ties or nest lab. She's interested in how close relationships affect health, particularly during major life changes, such as the transition to parenthood.
欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是达比·萨克斯比（Dr. Darby Saxby）博士。萨克斯比博士是南加州大学（University of Southern California）心理学副教授，她在该校领导社会联系神经内分泌学实验室（Neuroendocrinology of Social Ties Lab，简称 nest 实验室）。她主要研究亲密关系如何影响健康，特别是在为人父母等重大生活转折期间。
She has studied brain changes in both fathers and mothers, and how those changes are correlated with hormones and behavior. Her research has been featured in media, including The New York Times, The Washington Post and NPR, and she's working on a book called Dad Brain, slated for a release next year. Dr. Saxby, thank you for joining me. I'm very happy to be here. Thank you for having me. I mentioned that you're working on this book, Dad Brain,
她研究了父亲和母亲的大脑变化，以及这些变化与荷尔蒙和行为的相关性。她的研究成果已被《纽约时报》（The New York Times）、《华盛顿邮报》（The Washington Post）和美国国家公共电台（NPR）等媒体报道，她目前正在撰写一本名为《父亲大脑》（Dad Brain）的书，预计于明年出版。萨克斯比博士，非常感谢您能来。我很高兴来到这里。谢谢你们邀请我。我提到您正在撰写这本书——《父亲大脑》，
and people might have heard the term mom brain or mommy brain before, maybe used in a pejorative way. But what do you mean when you talk about dad brain or mom brain? Right. So what we're starting to discover, and there's this small but emerging neuroscience literature in humans, is that the brain is remodeled by parenthood. And we've known this for a while if you look at rodents,
人们以前可能听过“妈妈大脑”（mom brain）或“辣妈大脑”（mommy brain）这个词，有时甚至带有贬义。但是，当你们谈论“父亲大脑”或“母亲大脑”时，究竟是什么意思呢？没错。我们开始发现的是——并且人类神经科学领域已经有了这方面虽小但正在兴起的相关文献——大脑会被为人父母这一经历重塑。如果我们观察啮齿动物，
if you look at primates, that you see changes that are linked with adaptations that support nurturing a new infant. And it was really in 2016, there was a group in Spain that first looked longitudinally at moms who were recruited before becoming pregnant and then scanned for a second time a few months after the birth of an infant. What they found is going to sound like a bad joke, but it's actually, we think a good thing, which is the brain got smaller. So it lost some gray matter volume
如果我们观察灵长类动物，我们早就知道这一点：你会看到与支持抚育新生婴儿的适应性相关的变化。事实上，在 2016 年，西班牙的一个研究小组首次纵向研究了那些在怀孕前就被招募的母亲，并在婴儿出生几个月后对她们进行了第二次扫描。她们发现的结果听起来可能像个烂笑话，但实际上，我们认为这是一件好事，那就是大脑变小了。也就是说，在第一次孕前时间点和产后扫描之间，
between that first preconception time point and the postpartum scan. And we think that might be a process of streamlining and helping the brain work more efficiently when it comes to all the processing of social information that new parents have to do. So in much the same way that the brain actually loses volume in early childhood as connections are formed
它失去了一些灰质体积。我们认为这可能是一个精简的过程，有助于大脑在处理新手父母必须面对的所有社交信息时更高效地工作。这与幼儿期随着连接的形成和修剪的发生，大脑实际上会失去体积的原理非常相似。因此，母亲大脑体积减小的区域与心理化和社交认知有关，而那些体积减少更多的母亲，随后报告称她们与婴儿的亲密关系更深。因此，正当这项研究问世的同时，我正在收集正处于为人父母过渡期的父亲们的数据。所以，在我们在加州的实验室里，
and pruning occurs. So areas in which the moms lost brain volume were those linked with mentalizing and social cognition, and moms who lost more volume, subsequently reported stronger bonds with their infants. So I, at the same time that this study was coming out, was collecting data from dads who were transitioning to parenthood. So in our lab in California,
我们招募了期待第一个孩子的夫妇。我们在孕中期对这些男性进行了扫描，然后在产后大约六个月再次扫描。因此，我们的时间框架与西班牙的研究小组略有不同。但是，当我看到西班牙的研究小组拥有他们所追踪的女性的男性伴侣的样本时，
we recruited couples who were expecting their first child. We scanned the men in mid-pregnancy, and then again about six months postpartum. So our time frame was a little bit different from the group in Spain. But when I saw that the Spanish group had a sample of male partners of the women that they had followed,
我立刻——好吧，也不是立刻。过了几个月。我获得了富布赖特奖学金。我跳上飞机，去了西班牙。我试着说服他们与我合作。最终，我们得以汇集各自的样本。于是，我们采用了我样本中的前 20 位父亲，
I immediately, well, not immediately. It took a few months. I got a full bright. I hopped on a plane. I went to Spain. And I tried to convince them to collaborate with me. And eventually, we were able to pool our samples. So we took the first 20 dads from my sample,
以及他们扫描过的 20 位父亲，结果发现，在这两个样本中，我们在男性身上看到的改变，实际上与他们在母亲身上已经观察到的改变非常相似。而且只有一些不同之处。其中之一就是这些变化更加微妙。它们不那么引人注目。它们没有那么显著。对于母亲，你可以使用机器学习算法，基本上仅凭大脑结构就能判断一位母亲是处于孕前还是产后；而对于父亲，我们没有看到那么显著的效果。另一个不同之处在于，在母亲身上，你会看到大脑皮层的变化——这可以说是大脑组织的最外层，负责我们许多的高阶思维——以及皮层下结构，这更像是我们的“蜥蜴脑”，包括杏仁核以及一些更偏向情绪处理的区域。
the 20 does that they had scanned and found that across these two samples, we saw changes in the men that were actually really similar to the changes that they had already observed in the moms. And there were a few differences. One was that the changes were more subtle. They were less striking. They were less significant. So with the moms, you can use a machine learning algorithm that will basically tell you whether a mom is pre or postpartum just based on the brain structure. with the dads, we didn't see effects that were that striking. And the other difference was that in the moms, you saw changes to the cortex, which is sort of the top layer of brain tissue that does a lot of our higher order thinking. And the subcortex, which is more kind of our lizard brain that includes the amygdala and some of our more sort of emotion processing regions.
在父亲身上，我们只看到了大脑皮层的变化。这就是我们的重大发现，随后我在我的实验室里用更大样本的被扫描父亲复制了这一结果，并将其与我们收集的父亲们的一些育儿测量指标和其他测量指标联系起来。这种大脑体积会恢复吗？还是说这是永久性的？这是一个极好的问题，我们目前还没有确切的答案。西班牙的研究小组实际上在孩子出生七年后对其中一些母亲进行了扫描。他们发现大脑体积的减少在一定程度上得以保留。海马体等区域出现了反弹，但整个大脑总体上仍然比孕前稍微小一些，或者我喜欢称之为“更精干、更强健”。不过我应该指出，因为要在七年后追踪到这些人非常困难，他们的样本量非常小。
In the dads, we only saw changes to the cortex. So that was our big finding, and then I've subsequently replicated that in my lab with a bigger sample of the dads that I've scanned and connected that with some parenting measures and other measures that we've collected in our dads. Does that brain volume come back or is this permanent? That is an excellent question that we don't really know the answer to. So the Spanish group actually did scan some of the moms seven years after the birth of their child. And they found that there was some retention of the brain volume losses. There was rebound in areas like the hippocampus, but the brain overall was still a little bit smaller, or I like to say like leaner and meaner, that it was before pregnancy. So I should say, though, that because it's hard to track people down after seven years, they had a really small sample.
我想说，他们能够重新扫描的母亲大概只有十几个。所以我们目前实际上正在扫描我们样本中的父亲们。我们在进行七年后的随访。希望当我们完成这些数据的获取后，我们将能够回答男性身上关于这一点的某些问题。那么，这是在一个家庭第一个孩子出生之后。我们知道如果后面还有更多孩子，随后的出生会发生什么情况吗？是的，这也是一个我们没有答案的伟大问题。
I want to say it was like maybe a dozen moms that they were able to scan again. So we're now actually scanning the fathers in our sample. we're doing a seven-year follow-up. And hopefully when we finish acquiring that data, we'll be able to answer some questions about that in men. Now, this is after the birth of the first child in a household. Do we know what happens with subsequent births if there are more kids? Yeah, also a great question that we don't have the answer to.
所以我应该强调，这方面的文献真的很少。它才刚刚兴起。因此我们将在七年随访中研究这一点，因为我们的一些孩子确实有兄弟姐妹。所以我想说，现在略超一半的人有一个或两个兄弟姐妹。丹佛大学（University of Denver）的皮良·金（Piliang Kim）做过一项研究，研究对象是从产后一个月到四个月被追踪的父亲们；也就是说，所有的父亲都在出生后接受了扫描，
So I should emphasize this literature is really small. It's really emerging. So we will be looking at that with our seven-year follow-up because some of our kids do have siblings. so I would say a little over half now have a sibling or two. There was one study done by Piliang Kim at the University of Denver that looked at fathers who were followed from one to four months postpartum. So all the dads were scanned after birth,
但她在产后早期进行了两次扫描。她的样本中既有第一胎也有第二胎的父亲，但样本太小，无法真正观察到群体差异。因此，我真正好奇的问题之一是：父亲们是否会失去越来越多的体积？大脑是否变得越来越精简？还是说在达到一定程度后，当有了更多孩子时，会有更多的反弹？您还研究了男性成为父亲时可能发生的荷尔蒙变化。您能给我们多讲讲这项研究吗？您发现的一些变化是什么？它们对日常生活有什么影响？是的，所以通常当我们想到荷尔蒙和为人父母时，我们会想到怀孕和分娩，对吧？我们知道这些是荷尔蒙极其丰富的事件。但有充分的证据表明，我们在男性身上也能看到荷尔蒙的变化。
but she scanned twice in that early postpartum period. And she had a mix of first and second time dads, but the sample was too small to really look at group differences. So one of the questions that I would be really curious about is, Did dad sort of like lose more and more volume? Does the brain get more and more streamlined? Or at a certain point, is there more rebound once you have more kids? You've also looked at hormonal changes that can occur in men when they become fathers. Can you tell us more about that research? What are some of the changes that you found and what are the everyday impacts? Yeah, so often when we think about hormones and parenthood, we think about pregnancy and birth, right, which we know are really hormonally rich events. But there's plenty of evidence that we see hormone changes in men as well.
被研究得最多的荷尔蒙之一是睾酮，我们知道它是一种与力量、地位、统治力和男性第二性征有关的荷尔蒙。它在很大程度上与男性联系在一起，尽管女性也有可检测到的睾酮水平，但男性的水平要高出许多倍。我们通过观察双亲抚育后代的动物（如啮齿动物和灵长类动物）了解到，在后代出生前后，睾酮水平会下降。我们在人类身上也确实看到了同样的现象。因此，研究这一现象最令人印象深刻的研究之一是由圣母大学（University of Notre Dame）的李·格特勒（Lee Gettler）完成的。
One of the biggest hormones that has been studied is testosterone, which we know of is a hormone that's linked with power, status, dominance, male secondary sex characteristics. it's very much associated with men, even though women also have detectable testosterone levels, but men's levels are many times higher. And we know from looking at biparental animals like rodents and primates that there are testosterone drops around the birth of offspring. And we actually see the same thing in humans. And so one of the most kind of impressive studies to look at this was done by Lee Gettler, who's at University of Notre Dame.
这是一项来自菲律宾的非常大型的研究，他们随着时间的推移追踪了男性。他们拥有这些男性在 20 多岁时的睾酮测量数据，然后几年后又进行了复查。他们发现，与孩子共同居住的男性，尤其是花更多时间照顾孩子的男性，其睾酮水平较低。
This was a really big study from the Philippines, and they followed men over time. They had testosterone measures from when the men were in their 20s, and then they looked again years later. And they found that men who were residing with children, especially men who were spending more time caring for children, had lower testosterone.
这项研究帮助回答了“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的问题，即：究竟是睾酮水平较低的男性更容易被选择进入父母角色，所以他们一开始就较低并保持较低水平？还是说有什么东西在发生改变？因为他们拥有这些纵向数据，所以他们能够指出：实际上，成为父亲的男性在成为爸爸之前拥有更高的睾酮水平，然后他们表现出了更多的下降。因此，这似乎确实是随着时间推移发生的变化，并且与成为父亲息息相关。我在自己的实验室里复制了这一结果。我们测量了父亲们的睾酮水平。我们发现，较低的睾酮水平和睾酮水平的下降与参与婴儿护理的动机增强以及在向父母角色过渡期间更好的关系质量息息相关。
And that study helped answer the chicken egg question of, you know, is it that lower testosterone men are selected? into parenthood, so they started lower and they stayed lower, or is there something that's changing? Because they had this longitudinal data, they were able to say, actually, the men who became fathers had higher testosterone before they became dads, and then they showed more of a decline. So it really seems like there's a change over time that is linked with becoming a father. And I've replicated that result in my lab. We've measured testosterone and our dads. And we found that lower testosterone and a drop in testosterone are linked with more motivation to participate in
因此，荷尔蒙的变化确实带来了一些好处。对于男性来说，我听到了这些好处。那么对于女性呢，她们的荷尔蒙是如何变化的？是的。事实上，我们发现女性的荷尔蒙不仅会发生变化，而且对伴侣的变化也有所反应。因此我们做了一项研究，同时观察了母亲和父亲的产后抑郁症。我们发现，当父亲在孩子出生后大约九个月睾酮水平较低时，他们报告的抑郁情绪更多，但他们的伴侣在面对睾酮水平较低的男性时，实际上报告的抑郁情绪更少。
baby care and better relationship quality across the transition to parenthood. So there are some benefits then to the changes in the hormones. For men, I'm hearing what they are. What about for women, how do their hormones change? Yeah. So actually, we found that not only do women's hormones change, but they're also responsive to the changes in their partners. So we did a study where we looked at postpartum depression in both the mothers and the fathers. We found that when dads had lower testosterone about nine months after the birth of a child, they reported more depression, but their partners actually reported less depression when they were with lower testosterone men.
所以这有点像“彼之蜜糖，吾之砒霜”的情况。而且母亲身上的这种效应完全是由关系满意度介导的。如果你是一位新手妈妈，你的伴侣的睾酮水平在孩子出生前后可能以一种适应性的方式下降。这可能会让你建立起更好的共同育儿关系，并在一定程度上免受抑郁症的困扰。但对男性来说，可能存在一些心理健康风险，我认为我们需要对此有更多了解。不过，那篇论文得出的核心结论是：存在一个黄金平衡点。也就是说，睾酮水平过高或过低的男性情况都较糟，但中间有许多男性的抑郁风险似乎较低。
So there's a bit of a good for the goose, not good for the gander kind of situation happening. and that effect for moms was totally mediated by relationship satisfaction. So if you're a new mom, you have a partner whose testosterone is maybe dropping in an adaptive way around the birth of a child. That might set you up to have sort of better co-parenting relationship and be buffered against depression. But there might be some mental health risks for men that, you know, I think we need to understand more. The kind of takeaway from that paper, though, was that there is a happy medium. like men were doing worse at both very high and very low levels of testosterone, but there are a lot of men in the middle that seem to be a low risk for depression.
所以我不会希望男性听到这个后认为，“你知道的，因为宝宝出生前后睾酮下降，我的心理健康会变得糟糕透顶”。在大多数情况下，这些荷尔蒙的变化似乎真的具有很好的适应性。我也在想，有些男性听到这样的话可能会说：“是的，但是我的性欲会怎么样呢？对吧？”是的，而且我们知道，向父母角色的过渡是伴侣性生活的一次重大重组，对吧？因为通常在产后头几个月禁止进行性行为。而且，如果妈妈在母乳喂养，欲望也会发生变化，她可能不想被触碰，对吧？
So I wouldn't want men to listen to this and think, you know, like I'm going to have terrible mental health because of testosterone drops around the birth of the baby. For the most part, it seems like these hormonal changes are really adaptive. And I'm thinking also there are some men who may hear something like this and say, yeah, but what happens to my sex drive, right? Yeah, well, and we know that the transition to parenthood is a big kind of reorganization of the couple's sexual activity, right? Because often there's prohibition against having sex in the first few months after birth. And, you know, there's change in desire if the mom's breastfeeding, she may not want to be touched, right?
就像伴侣关系中有很多事情正在发生一样。因此，性欲的暂时下降可能并不是世界上最糟糕的事情。而且，当我们思考进化理论时，我们会思考交配和育儿之间的权衡是什么，对吧？所以，如果我们处于交配阶段，我们希望尽可能多地生孩子。我们希望最大化我们繁殖的机会，而如果我们处于更有养育心态时，我们希望照顾我们已经拥有的孩子，并确保他们能够活到成年。随着社会变得越来越富裕和稳定，利用那种更具养育性的行为库实际上更具适应性。你不需要
Like there's a lot that's going on kind of in terms of the couple relationship. So, you know, a temporary drop in sex drive might not be the worst thing in the world. And, you know, when we're thinking about evolutionary theory, we think about what is the tradeoff between mating and parenting, right? So if we're sort of in a mating place, we want to have as many babies as we possibly can. We want to maximize our opportunities to reproduce, whereas if we're more in a nurturing mindset, we want to take care of the babies that we do have and ensure that they live to adulthood. And as societies get richer and more stable, it's actually more adaptive to use that sort of more nurturing repertoire. You don't need to
生下一打孩子来指望其中几个能幸存下来。实际上，你往往会将大量投资投入到仅仅几个孩子身上。我们在工业化社会中看到，家庭规模变得越来越小。这伴随着人们执行生殖策略方式的转变。让我们花一分钟谈谈睡眠作为这些变化中一个因素的影响。我的意思是，为人父母的头几个月通常伴随着严重的睡眠剥夺。这会是这些大脑变化的另一个因素吗？绝对是的。我认为这就是——每当我向任何人讲述关于大脑荷尔蒙或心理健康的任何工作时，他们总是说：“嗯，对，这可能是因为睡眠剥夺。”
have a dozen kids in hopes that a couple of them will survive. You actually tend to put a lot of investment into just a couple of kids. And we see that in industrialized societies, that family sizes get smaller. And that's kind of accompanied with a shift in how people enact their reproductive strategies. Let's talk for a minute about sleep as a factor in some of these changes. I mean, the first few months of parenthood generally involve a lot of sleep deprivation. Could that be another factor in these brain changes? Absolutely. And I think that's kind of the, anytime I tell anybody about any of this work with brain hormones or mental health, they always say, well, right, it's probably because of sleep deprivation.
因此我们在实验室里测量了睡眠。我们发现，当父亲们有更多的大脑灰质体积减少时，他们也报告说睡眠更差。但睡眠似乎并不是大脑改变的原因，而是结果。我们发现，在向父母角色过渡期间失去更多灰质体积的男性，其实在出生前并没有更糟糕的睡眠，但他们在出生后会有逐渐变差的睡眠。因此，当你试图厘清这种因果方向时，很难知道究竟是什么先发生：是大脑重组还是睡眠变化，因为当我们更有动力并积极参与育儿时，我们的睡眠会变差，对吧？因为我们要更频繁地起床照顾婴儿，因此我们的睡眠更加被打扰。
And so we've measured sleep in our lab. We found that when dads have more brain, gray matter, volume reduction, they also report worse sleep. But it seems like the sleep is actually not the cause, but the consequence of brain change. So we find that men who lose more gray matter volume across the transition to parenthood actually don't have worse sleep before birth, but they have sort of increasingly worse sleep after birth. So when you're sort of teasing out that direction of causality, it's a little bit hard to know what happens first, brain reorganization or sleep. changes because when we're more motivated and engaged in parenting, we have worse sleep, right, because we're getting up more often with the baby, and therefore our sleep is more
我对“妈妈大脑”这个词的理解还指代这样一个事实：有些女性在生完孩子后开始觉得，“我什么都记不住了，我不知道把钥匙放哪儿了，我今天在干什么？”在这些情况下，男性的身上也会发生同样的事情吗？是的，实际上有越来越多关于母性认知变化的文献。而且，就像你说的，“妈妈大脑”往往被贬低为一种让你变得不那么聪明的存在。但实际上有大量证据表明，在成为母亲之后，你的认知功能变得更加敏锐，表现在你拥有更强的能力去记忆和检索特定于你婴儿的事物，对吧？所以，如果你想想一只带着一堆小动物到处跑的啮齿动物，你可能会忘记把它们放在了哪里。因此，嗅觉和海马体中有许多与幼崽检索相关的东西，比如能够找到你的幼崽、闻到它们并把它们带回来。而在人类中，显然我们不会去闻那些已经离开基地的婴儿。但在早期的育儿过程中，我们需要记住许多不同的事情，并且对婴儿的特定刺激做出反应。所以情况可能并非是我们变得更加健忘，而是实际上我们有
disturbed. My understanding of the term mommy brain also refers to the fact that some women after giving birth start to feel like, I can't remember anything, I don't know where I put my keys, what am I doing today? It's the same thing happening to men under these circumstances? Yeah, so there's actually this growing literature looking at cognitive changes. with motherhood. And, you know, like you said, like mommy brain is often kind of disparaged as like this thing that makes you less smart. There's actually a lot of evidence that you sharpen your
更多的事情需要监控。因此有一篇论文，由法国雷恩大学（University of Rennes）的茱蒂·波卢斯基（Jody Poluski）撰写，其中指出：是时候给“妈妈大脑”重新塑造品牌了。在许多方面，我们实际上应该认为它在涉及某些事情时变得更加敏锐和具体。你可能会更好地检索特定于婴儿的线索，但对其他不那么重要的事情的检索可能会变差。我的直觉是，虽然没有人真正研究过父亲的认知功能，但我认为我们可能会看到类似的情况：只要你参与育儿，你就会追踪大量与婴儿相关的信息，因此你可能会对其他一些事情失去掌控——也就是你试图去跟踪的其他信息片段。
cognitive functioning after motherhood in the sense that you have more ability to remember and retrieve things that are specific to your infant, right? So like if you think about a rodent who has a whole bunch of babies running around, you can kind of forget where you put them. And so like there's a lot of stuff with like smell and the hippocampus that's linked with pup retrieval, like being able to find your pup smell them and bring them back. And in humans, you know, obviously we're not smelling our babies who, you know, have left the premises. But we do need to remember a lot of different things when we're parenting in the early days and to be responsive to the specific stimulus of the babies. So it may be the case, not that we're becoming more forgetful, but actually just that we have
我认为这一切真正有趣的地方在于，越来越多的证据表明，为人父母在晚年具有神经保护作用。因此，来自英国生物样本库（UK Biobank）和其他一些大数据来源的研究将孩子的数量与我们认为是年轻大脑标志物的指标联系起来。这在男性和女性身上都适用，这告诉我们这不仅仅是怀孕荷尔蒙的事情。
more things to monitor. And so there's a paper, Jody Poluski, who's at the University of Ren in France, wrote that it says it's time to rebrand mommy brain. We should actually think of it in a lot of ways as becoming more sharp and specific when it comes to certain things. You might have better retrieval of baby-specific cues, but worse retrieval of other things that aren't as important. And my hunch is no one has really studied cognitive function in dads, but I think we would probably see something similar to the extent that you're engaging in caregiving, you're tracking a lot of information relevant to your baby, and so you might be losing your handle on some of the other things, you know, some of the other pieces of information that you're trying to keep track of.
这是一项照顾经历的事情，如果你使用年龄调整算法来估计大脑看起来有多大，大脑实际上在拥有更多孩子的人群中显得相对更年轻。因此，无论早期父母生活中的大脑发生了什么，很难知道它是好是坏。但看起来，归根结底，你得到了一些好处。
And I think the really interesting thing about all of this is that there's this increasing body of evidence that parenthood is neuroprotective in late life. So work from the UK Biobank and other sort of big data sources are linking number of children with markers of what we consider to be a younger-looking brain. And this is true in both men and women, which tells us that it isn't just a pregnancy hormone thing.
您是如何首次对这一研究方向产生兴趣的？我一直对家庭和为人父母非常着迷。而且，我认为我的父母离婚了，所以我一直对婚姻以及伴侣如何解决问题非常感兴趣，因为我有一种——你知道的，任何心理学家的研究都是“自我搜索”（me search），你想要理解那些能修复你自己的生活的事情。因此，作为一名研究生，我加入了加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的这个实验室，该实验室致力于处理来自“家庭日常生活中心”（Center for Everyday Lives of Families）的数据。这是一个大型的心理学、人类学、语言学、考古学合作项目，我们基本上进入了美国家庭的家中住了一周，
It's like a caregiving experience thing that the brain actually, if you use a sort of age-adjusted algorithm to estimate how old the brain looks, it looks relatively younger among people that have had more kids. So whatever's happening to the brain in early parenthood, it's hard to know whether it's good or bad. But it seems like, you know, at the end of the day, you get some benefits.
并且无时无刻不在跟踪他们。我们记下他们做的一切。我们提取他们的压力荷尔蒙。我们问了他们很多问题。这简直是一个非常有趣的语料库，通过它来观察家庭生活。我对压力、父母尤其是带孩子的父母如何管理家庭非常感兴趣。但我当时想，如果我对试图改善现状抱有任何希望，我可能想要回到最初家庭刚形成的时候去试图理解：有没有办法在压力和逆境出现之前就预防它们？这让我对向父母角色的过渡产生了非常具体的兴趣。作为一名伴侣研究员，我对此很感兴趣：二元组合是如何变成三元组合的，这对伴侣意味着什么？
How did you first become interested in this line of research? I've always been really fascinated with families and parenthood. And, you know, I think my parents are divorced, so I was always very interested in marriage and how couples figure things out because I sort of, you know, like any psychologist research and is me search and you want to understand the things that would fix your own life. And so as a graduate student, I joined this lab at UCLA that was working with the data from the Center for Everyday Lives of Families, which was this big kind of psychology, anthropology, linguistics, archaeology, collaboration where we basically went into families' homes for a week
所以我有点像一个逆向的儿童发展学者，因为我从父母开始。我们倾向于考虑婴儿期和幼儿期的发展窗口期，但我认为当人们成为父母时，也有发展窗口期。大脑在改变。荷尔蒙也在改变。你的社会角色也在改变。因此，我实际上对等式的成年人这一侧感兴趣，因为我认为如果你没有优秀健康的父母，你就不会有优秀健康的孩子，这进而会影响整个社会。所以我有点从等式的另一端切入。与生命其他阶段的大脑变化相比，为人父母前后的大脑变化有何不同？整个成年期的大脑结构通常都会发生变化，还是说您在向父母角色过渡时看到的变化非常具体和独特？
and we followed them around. We wrote down everything they did. We took their stress hormones. We asked them lots of questions. And it was just this really interesting corpus. of data kind of observing family life. And I was very interested in stress and parents and especially parents with kids, how they were managing the household. But I thought if I'm going to have any hope of trying to make things better, I want to maybe go back to the origin of when the family is first formed to try to understand. Are there ways to prevent stress and adversity before they arise? So that got me very specifically interested in transition to parenthood. And as kind of a couple's research. I was interested in that, like, how does a dyad become a triad and what does that do to the
是的。所以很难有极佳的研究设计来测量这一点，因为许多现有的研究规模都很小，而且它们并不总是设有对照组。因此，如果我们只是追踪 30 岁出头的人几年，我们会看到类似于我们在父母身上捕捉到的重塑吗？我不这么认为，因为我们似乎看到了这些不一定与实际年龄挂钩的持续变化。不过，大脑在整个生命周期中结构上的动态变化程度如何，仍然是我们有待更好地理解的问题。我要说的是，西班牙的研究小组确实做过一项研究，他们比较了青春期的大脑变化
couple? So I'm sort of like a backwards child development person in the sense that I start with the parents. We think of sort of developmental windows in infancy and early childhood, but I think there are also developmental windows when people become parents. The brain's also changing. Hormones are also changing. Your social roles are also changing. So I'm actually interested in the adult side of the equation because I think if you don't have good healthy parents, you don't have good healthy kids, and then it affects the whole society. So I'm kind of going at it from the other side of the equation. How do the brain changes around parenthood compare with brain changes at other stages in life? Does brain structure generally change throughout adulthood or the changes that you see
与怀孕和产后早期的大脑变化。他们发现两者的量级相似。因此，我们认为青春期是神经重塑的一个窗口期。而向父母角色的过渡似乎是第三个窗口期。如果你把幼儿期看作你的第一个窗口期，对吧？比如婴儿期，大脑在生长和重塑。青春期是你的第二个窗口期。向父母角色的过渡是你的第三个窗口期，在这个时期存在增强的神经可塑性。
with the transition to parenthood very specific and unique? Yeah. So it's hard to have great research designs to measure that because a lot of the studies out there are small and they don't always have control groups. So, you know, if we were to just track people in their early 30s for a couple years, would we see remodeling similar to what we're picking up on in parents? I don't think so because it seems like we're seeing these consistent changes that aren't necessarily tied to chronological age. But the question of how dynamic is the brain structurally across the lifespan is one that we still need to understand better. I will say like the Spanish group did a study where they compared brain changes in adolescence
这在进化上是有道理的，因为我们有一整套需要学习的行为，并且我们需要从中获得回报，这与青春期的情况相同：在青春期，我们需要实现个体化，我们需要建立同伴关系。我们在青春期需要做很多事情，这与我们在童年时期的任务截然不同。我认为向父母角色的过渡也是如此。而且我认为围绕着衰老，还有另一个重塑窗口期，在这个时期你也会看到很大的变异性。你会看到一些适应性的变化。
with brain changes across pregnancy and early postpartum. And they found that they were of similar magnitude. So we think of adolescence as this window of neural remodeling. And it seems like the transition to parenthood is sort of a third window. Like if you think of early childhood is your first window, right? Like infancy, the brain is growing and remodeling. Adolescence is your second window. transition to parenthood is your third window where there's kind of enhanced neuroplasticity.
我们才刚刚开始弄清楚更年期大脑发生了什么——女性在我们的脑科学研究中受到的研究太少了。我们对女性大脑健康的了解还远远不够。但那是你看到荷尔蒙变化的另一个时期。因此，我认为有很大的潜力去更好地理解这些可塑性窗口。我们要稍作休息。回来后，我们将讨论产假如何影响父亲和母亲的压力与心理健康。你有没有重新摆放过家具，却发现底下的地毯看起来崭新无比，而其余部分看起来……嗯，没那么新？
And that would make evolutionary sense because we have this whole repertoire of behaviors that we need to learn and we need to derive reward from in the same way than adolescence, we need to individuate, we need to create peer relationships. There's a lot that we need to be able to do with adolescence is distinct from what our jobs were in childhood. And I think that's true of the transition to parenthood. And then I think there's another window of remodeling around aging where you also see a lot of variability. You see some adaptive changes.
是时候升级地毯了。在全国家居建材（The Home Depot），我们以实惠的价格提供来自各大顶尖品牌的时尚选择。最棒的是，我们可以为你安装，每平方英尺仅需 49 美分起。所以你只需挑选你完美的地毯。今天就在全国家居建材开启你的地毯项目。实干家成就更多。限制条件适用，有关许可信息请参见 Home Depot.com 上的许可编号。
We're just starting to figure out what is happening with the menopausal brain. Like women have been so understudied in our brain research. We don't know enough about brain health and women. But that's another time when you see changes in hormones. And so, you know, there's a lot of potential, I think, to better understand these windows of plasticity. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about how paternity leave affects stress and mental health for fathers and mothers. Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new, while the rest of it looks, well, not so new?
你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些“步”在哪里。我们省了多少钱？
It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49 cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done. Exclusions apply for licenses see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
够了。够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用（Hilton app）上预订，最高可省 20%，享受您所期望的住宿体验。
Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or The Hilton. Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected.
当您想要节省开销，而不是意外惊喜时。您住在哪裏至关重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦常在。您研究过的另一个领域是陪产假的影响，不仅对爸爸，对妈妈也是如此。您发现了什么？让我们来谈谈这个。所以我们很幸运能在加州收集数据，
When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. Another area you've looked at is the impact of paternal leave, not just on dads, but on moms as well. What did you find? Let's talk about that. So we were lucky to be in California where we were collecting our data
因为并非每个州都有这种选择，但加州确实为爸爸们提供了一项伤残假选择。因此，我们样本中大约有一半的爸爸能够以某种方式获得带薪陪产假。当我们仅仅观察有权享受带薪陪产假和没有权享受带薪陪产假的爸爸们之间简单的群体差异时，我们观察了从产前到产后的压力、心理健康和睡眠。我们发现爸爸们从获得带薪假中获得了一些好处，比如他们拥有更好的睡眠和压力轨迹。但真正获得最大好处的是妈妈们。因此，她们拥有更好的抑郁症轨迹。
because not every state has this, but California does have a disability leave option for dads. So about half of the dads in our sample had some kind of access to paid paternity leave. And when we looked at just a simple kind of group difference between dads who did and didn't have access to paid paternity leave, we looked at prenatal to postpartum, stress, mental health, and sleep. We found that dads had some benefit from the access to paid leave, like they had, you know, better trajectories of sleep and stress. But it was really the moms that had the biggest benefit So they had better trajectories of depression.
她们患产后抑郁症的可能性更小，压力更小，并且在向父母角色过渡期间睡眠更好。所以我认为陪产假是那种真正不仅造福爸爸，而且造福整个家庭的事情。我们知道它对孩子有好处。我们也知道它对伴侣有好处。作为一名压力研究员，我认为你可以做的任何事情来减轻家庭系统的压力——因此任何形式的带薪假，无论是给妈妈还是给爸爸，我认为都非常有益。你肯定会在其他国家看到这一点，那里有某种陪产假激励措施
They were less likely to develop postpartum depression. They were less stressed and they had better sleep across the transition to parenthood. So I think a paternity leave is one of those things that really benefits, not just dads, but the whole family. We know that it has benefits for kids. We also know that it has benefits for the partner. And I think anything as a stress researcher, it's like anything you can do to relieve stress on the family system. So any form of paid leave, whether to mom or to dad, I think can be really beneficial. And you certainly see that in other countries where there are sort of paternity leave incentives
或鼓励更多父亲休假的计划项目。在我看来，这项研究应该具有一些公共政策含义。我的意思是，我们如何从基础研究走向现实，我们如何应用这一点并获得能够让每个人都从你正在了解的事物中受益的改变？这就是我无时无刻不在思考的问题，对吧？因此，如果我们将其视为神经可塑性的一个窗口期，我们如何减少我们知道对大脑有害的压力？我们如何为健康的改变留出空间和时间？对吧？因为如果你想想，每一个改变的窗口期都是一个脆弱的窗口期，但它也是一个机遇的窗口期。你如何最大化那个机遇？
or take up programs that nudge more fathers into taking leave. It sounds to me like there should be some public policy implications of this research. I mean, how do we go from, you know, the bench to reality, how do we apply this and get the changes that would let everybody benefit from what you're learning? This is what I think about all the time, right? So if we think of this as a window of neuroplasticity, how do we reduce stress, which we know is bad for the brain? How do we allow space and time for healthy change? Right? Because if you think about, you know, every window of change is a window of vulnerability, but it's also a window of opportunity. How do you maximize that opportunity?
所以我认为研究中存在一种有趣的双代框架。因此，你不仅在观察儿童的成长结果，你还在观察父母的心理健康和父母的心理结果。我认为不考虑父母身上正在发生的事情，就真的无法研究孩子。现在人们对青年焦虑和抑郁的这种流行病有着极大的关注。但事实是，看看年轻人的父母，他们也在苦苦挣扎。而且我认为，你需要关注整个家庭系统。所以现在有趣的是，有各种各样催生鼓励生育的言论。比如昨天《纽约时报》发表了一篇文章，说特朗普政府希望
So I think there's an interesting kind of two generation frameworks within research. So you're looking at child outcomes, but you're also looking at parental mental health and parental psychological outcomes. I think you can't really study kids without considering what's happening for parents. And there's so much concern now about this epidemic of youth anxiety and depression. But the fact is you look at parents of young people and they are also struggling. And I think, you know, you sort of need to pay attention to the whole family system. So what's interesting right now is that there's all this kind of pronatal. talk. Like there was a New York Times article out yesterday saying that Trump administration wants
让人多生孩子。但这并没有与能够激励人们健康生育的政策相结合，对吧？例如，我们在削减“开端计划”（Head Start）经费的同时。我们在撤销医疗补助计划（Medicaid）的资金，许多新生儿就是在那里诞生的。为什么我们没有为新手父母提供全民带薪家庭假？其他每一个工业化国家都有。甚至是那些比我们更富裕、比我们没那么富裕的国家，都已经设法弄清楚了如何提供慷慨的家庭假。有一个统计数据表明，在美国，大约四分之一的妈妈在产后两周内就回去工作了，这在我看来简直是彻底的疯狂。
to get people to have more babies. But that isn't coupled with the kinds of policies that would motivate healthy baby having, right? Like we're cutting head start at the same time. We're defunding Medicaid, which is where a lot of births happen. Why don't we have universal paid family leave for new parents, every other industrialized country has it. Even countries that are much wealthier, much less wealthy than us, have managed to figure out how to give generous family leaves. And there's a statistic that in the U.S., about a quarter of bombs go back to work within two weeks of birth, which to me is just complete insanity.
如果我们不能允许父母有机会与新出生的孩子建立亲密关系，我们作为一个国家究竟在做什么？而且我认为我们对为人父母有着非常个人主义的框架。这是一种选择。如果你决定生孩子，照顾他们就是你的工作。我真的认为我们需要退后一步思考：孩子是一项公共利益。我们需要健康的婴儿。我们需要健康的孩子，因为那是我们未来的劳动力。那是我们的国家安全。
Like, what are we doing as a country if we can't allow parents the ability to bond with new kids? And I think it's like we have this very individualistic framework around parenthood. It's a choice. If you decide to have kids, it's your job to take care of them. And I really think we need to step back and think about like kids are a public good. We want healthy babies. We want healthy kids because that's our future workforce. That's our national security.
无论我们自己是否选择生孩子，这些人最终都将在我们老去时照顾我们。我们所有人都能从拥有健康、快乐、成长且蓬勃发展的孩子中受益。当我们开始将其视为一项公共利益时，我认为我们可以为我们知道能够支持家庭度过过渡时期的那种政策释放出更多的政治意愿。您最近在的一篇新闻文章中被引述，谈到了在研究中纳入多样化人群的重要性。您是否研究过人们的早期为人父母体验如何随种族、族裔和社会经济地位而变化？是的，所以我们知道诸如产后抑郁症等结果存在很大变异性，
Those are the people they're going to be taking care of us when we're old, whether or not we ourselves choose to have kids. we all benefit from having healthy, happy kids who are growing and thriving. And when we start to think of it as a public good, then I think we can unlock a little more political will for the kinds of policies that we know can support families during times of transition. You were recently quoted in a news article about the importance of including diverse populations in research. Have you looked at how people's experience of early parenthood varies by race, ethnicity and socioeconomic status. Yeah, so we know there's a lot of variability in outcomes like postpartum depression,
压力和早期为人父母与社会经济地位等因素息息相关。我们知道贫困确实具有破坏性，部分原因是我们一直在讨论的家庭假问题。在我的研究中，由于我们的样本量相当小，我们无法深入探讨群体差异。我们已经尽力招募了我们所能做到的最具多样性和代表性的样本。但除了社会人口统计学差异之外，
stress and early parenthood that are linked with things like socioeconomic status. We know that poverty is really detrimental, in part because of the family leave piece that we were talking about. And in my study is because we have pretty small samples, we haven't been able to dig too much to group differences. We've tried to recruit the most diverse and representative sample that we can. But in addition to sort of socio-demographic differences,
考虑文化也非常重要，因为我们如何为人父母以及我们如何对待育儿的方式，在很大程度上与我们自身的养育方式息息相关。而且，拥有跨代同堂的家庭是规范吗？以不同的方式进行育儿是规范吗？
it's also really important to consider culture because so much of how we parent and how we approach parenting is linked to how we ourselves were raised. And, you know, is it normative to have intergenerational households? Is it normative to, you know, parent in a different way?
我的意思是，我有点认为我们所有人天生就是为了在社群中抚养孩子的，而我们这种非常孤立的育儿模式正注定让我们所有人都不快乐。但你可以看到不同文化之间在人们如何处理这一问题上存在着很大的变异性。今天我们主要讨论的是新手父母，但我也想问问你最近写的一篇专栏文章。它发表在《纽约时报》上，关于“低度育儿”（under-parenting）。这个观点是：给孩子更多感到无聊的空间对孩子和父母都有好处。是什么促使你写了那篇专栏文章？它与你关于育儿的研究有什么联系？是的，所以我是一名临床心理学家，但我也是一个极其懒散的妈妈。所以，你知道，我想写写这种给孩子留出空闲时间的想法。
I mean, I sort of think that all of us were designed to raise kids in community, and our very isolated model of parenthood is setting us all up to be unhappy. But you can see a lot of variability across cultures and how people approach that. Now, we're mostly talking about new parenthood today, but I also want to ask you about an op-ed that you wrote recently. It was published in the New York Times about under-parenting. The idea that giving kids more space to be bored is good for both kids and parents. What prompted you to write that op-ed and how does it tie in with your research on parenting? Yeah, so I'm a clinical psychologist, but I'm also an extremely lazy mom. And so, you know, I wanted to write about this idea of giving kids downtime,
我的意思是，我某种程度上觉得我们所有人本来就应该在社区中共同抚育孩子，而我们这种非常孤立的育儿模式正注定让我们所有人都不快乐。但你可以看到，不同的文化以及人们对待这一点的方式存在很大差异。现在，我们今天主要讨论的是新手父母阶段，但我也想问问你关于你最近写的一篇专栏文章。它发表在《纽约时报》上，主题是过度育儿的反面——适度放手。这个观点认为，给孩子更多无聊的空间对孩子和父母都有好处。是什么促使你写那篇专栏文章的？它与你关于育儿的研究有什么联系？是的，所以，我是一名临床心理学家，但我也是一个极其懒惰的妈妈。所以，你知道的，我想写关于给孩子留出空闲时间的这个想法，
giving them space to be bored, not letting them get overoccupied. Because I think one of the things that is causing stress for parents and is actually dampening the birth rate is this sort of intensive style of parenthood that has really just become prevalent in the last few decades. So Alison Gopnik has written about this. Like the use of parenting as a verb is actually relatively recent. It's from the 1970s that we thought of parenting is like an activity that you do as opposed to just something that you are.
给孩子一些无聊的空间，不要让他们被安排得太满。因为我认为，给父母造成压力并实际上在拉低生育率的原因之一，就是这种近年来才真正流行起来的集约式育儿风格。艾莉森·戈普尼克（Alison Gopnik）就此写过文章。比如，把“育儿”（parenting）用作动词其实是比较晚近的事。从20世纪70年代开始，我们才把育儿视为一项你去做的工作，而不是仅仅代表你的某种身份。
So, you know, we have this style that's very effortful. It's always on. It's very child-centered. We take kids to lots of activities. We spend a lot of time shuttling them around. And it's very unusual, kind of historically, if you think about the fact that in lots of cultures, kids aren't necessarily given lots of special activities to, you know, be escorted to. It's more like they're following adults around.
所以，你知道的，我们有这种非常费精力的风格。它总是处于开启状态，非常以孩子为中心。我们带孩子参加很多活动。我们花大量时间开车接送他们。从历史上看，这很不寻常，如果你考虑到这样一个事实：在许多文化中，孩子们不一定有那么多专门的活动需要护送去参加。更多的时候，他们只是跟着大人到处走。
They're modeling. They're learning from what adults in the community do. And they're contributing oftentimes very useful labor to the communities. So we sort of have it backwards where I think we're rushing around trying to please our kids, as opposed to our kids actually learning from us doing the things that we need to do as adults. And my interest in this, like I said, I'm a very lazy mom, but it also just comes from studying parents and studying stress in parents and thinking about, you know, how is it we've crafted this style of parenting
他们在模仿。他们从社区成年人所做的事情中学习。而且他们经常为社区贡献非常有用劳动力。所以我们有点本末倒置了，我认为我们四处奔忙试图取悦我们的孩子，而不是让孩子通过观察我们做成年人需要做的事情来向我们学习。我对这个感兴趣，就像我说的，我是一个非常懒散的妈妈，但它也源于对父母的研究、对父母压力的研究，以及思考我们究竟是如何塑造出这种育儿风格的——
and these expectations around parenting that feel pretty unsustainable, I think, for a lot of people. And what's interesting is if you look at the Time Diary trends from the 50s to today, we think of the 50s as like this golden age of kind of like June Cleaver, like doting motherhood, wearing an apron, you're always home. Moms in the 50s actually spent less time per day than moms do now. And what's interesting too is dads are also spending more time than they did in the 50s. So it's like the kid is just getting a lot more time with parents. Like we've just, you know, our model of parenthood is much more time intensive than it was a couple generations ago. You know, and I'm not even that old, but, you know, when I was a kid in the 80s, I would just sort of like roam around my neighborhood and look for a neighbor to play with.
以及围绕育儿的这些期望，我认为对于很多人来说，这些期望让人感觉相当难以持续。有趣的是，如果你看看从20世纪50年代到今天的“时间日记”趋势，我们认为50年代是那种像琼·克利弗（June Cleaver）一样的黄金时代，比如溺爱的母亲、系着围裙、总是呆在家里。事实上，50年代的妈妈们每天花在孩子身上的时间比现在的妈妈还要少。同样有趣的是，爸爸们花的时间也比50年代多。所以这就好像孩子从父母那里得到了更多的时间。我们的育儿模式比几代人之前要耗费多得多的时间。你知道的，我也不是那么老，但是，当我还是80年代的小孩时，我基本上就是在我居住的社区周围闲逛，找邻居一起玩。
And now, you know, the sort of modern style of parenthood is you organize a play date, you've set out snacks, you've got crafts ready to go. It's all very curated, but it's not in the service of kids' ability to get unstructured play, which I would argue is kind of the central way that kids learn in childhood. I'm with you. I'm a boomer, and my mother would say, just get out of the house. I don't care. Just don't hurt yourself. Goodbye. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, it was like if I was home for dinner, great, nobody worried. You know, I'm sure my parents had no idea where I was between the hours of 3 and 6 p.m. every afternoon after school. So what are you working on now? It sounds like there's still a lot of questions regarding dad brains. Do you have more research underway at the moment? Yes. So I mentioned we're doing our seven-year follow-up, so we're bringing the families that we originally recruited in pregnancy back to the lab. So the kids are six and seven years old now. The goal is to look at how prenatal stress and adaptation around the transition to parenthood affects child outcomes in middle childhood. And we're having the families do some interactive activities. They're building a tower with blocks. They're doing an etch-a-sketch, we're looking at sort of joint play and attention. And we're having having the families engage in some discussions, too, about how the kid is faring and how the division of labor is going for the parents. So some of the same constructs that we were looking at in the first wave of the study. So we're about two-thirds the way through collecting that data. Hopefully we'll be able to analyze it and have some results in the next five years or so.
而现在，现代的育儿风格是你组织一次约玩（play date），准备好零食，备好手工艺品。这一切都经过了精心策划，但这并不是为了培养孩子们进行无结构游戏的能力，而我认为这是孩子们在童年时期学习的核心方式。我懂你的意思。我是婴儿潮一代，我母亲会说，滚出屋子去。我不在乎。只要别把自己弄伤就行。再见。是啊。是啊。我的意思是，如果我回家吃晚饭，那就太好了，没有人担心。你知道的，我敢肯定，每天下午放学后下午3点到6点之间，我父母根本不知道我在哪里。那么你现在在忙些什么呢？听起来关于“父亲大脑”似乎还有很多问题。你目前还有其他正在进行的研究吗？是的。正如我所提到的，我们正在做七年的后续研究，所以我们把最初在怀孕期间招募的家庭请回了实验室。所以现在的孩子已经六、七岁了。我们的目标是观察孕期压力以及向为人父母过渡期间的适应过程，如何影响儿童在儿童中期时期的发展结果。我们让这些家庭做一些互动活动。他们用积木搭塔。他们在玩磁性画板（etch-a-sketch），我们观察他们的共同游戏和注意力。我们还让家庭参与一些讨论，讨论孩子的近况以及父母之间家务分工的进展情况。这与我们在研究第一阶段所关注的结构有些相似。所以我们已经完成了大约三分之二的数据收集工作。希望我们能够在未来五年左右对这些数据进行分析并得出一些结果。
And then my other big thing is writing books. So I wrote the, I mean, it's not out yet. It'll be out next spring, spring 2026, the dad brain book. But I just turned in the manuscript a couple months ago and I'll be working on that with my editor. And I was so fun to write and I just loved it. It was such a delight to not have to write statistics and research articles. Like I love writing research papers, but it was so fun to just get to tell stories and not have to worry so much about, you know, going through the peer review gauntlet. And now I'm writing my second book and it's going to be about this underparenting concept and sort of how not to be a helicopter parent, and how parents can relax and enjoy their kids more.
然后我的另一件大事是写书。所以我写了——我的意思是，它还没出版。它将在明年春天、2026年春天出版，也就是那本关于父亲大脑的书。但我几个月前刚交了书稿，我将和我的编辑一起处理它。写这本书太有趣了，我太喜欢了。不用写统计数据和研究论文，这真是一大乐事。虽然我很喜欢写研究论文，但只需讲故事而不必担心经历同行评议的严酷考验，这真是太有趣了。现在我正在写我的第二本书，它将关于这种“过度放任式育儿”（underparenting）的概念，以及如何不做一个直升机父母，以及父母如何放松并更多地享受和孩子在一起的时光。
So I'm hoping to dive into that soon too. Well, Dr. Saxby, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been a lot of fun talking to you. It's been a pleasure. Thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave us a review.
所以我希望很快也能深入研究那个课题。萨克斯比博士，我想感谢你今天能来。和你聊天非常愉快。我也很高兴。非常感谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org上，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何您收听播客的地方，找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并给我们留个评价。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup.
如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·维纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松心情，本周让拉尔夫（Ralph's）配送帮您搞定食品杂货采购。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后核对您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们将所有商品打包，并在短短30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。新鲜杂货，随心所欲，尽在拉尔夫配送与自提服务。
And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单还可以省下20美元。拉尔夫，新鲜面向每个人。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。